welcome to this video playing IVA IVA
IVA wgm ok set in a eva vida nova ah
garyun champion ok let's not the
bulgarian flag that's a croatia right
yeah I've learned that creation and
sodium and it's the most of the time I
get it right so we have the goon fat and
going for this funky h4 line haven't had
this in a while ok if the response is
not coming immediately that's good news
if they don't know the line and he it's
normally quite quite promising ok ok so
i can even go a 5 now Bishop c4 both
good job let's let's take here first ok
now e5 she's going to take on the f 3 SC
so how would you play that I'd like to
get any five maybe I can prepare it the
idea is to just get out of the pin I'm
not be three it's not a great square for
the Queen mad I mean I'm really never
threatening to take on b7 I guess yeah I
mean this is a case of having said a you
have to have to play it have to do this
it's it's risky quite clearly I have my
development is not great but it is a it
is a very very very big Center um so we
should be three I guess okay possibly
yeah but okay night before I will just
take so this is some not dangerous and
now I'm threatening me five and pushing
black of the border end HyperMatter
hyper-modern opening and what not but if
he five is coming black is going to get
wiped out yeah and here again 85 this is
this is this is just lost for black if
I'm not screwing it up let's see Queen
to b4 to a 3 or 2 c 2 e mc2 probably is
the best team getting the Queen near the
king in a way um so II 6 here why now
there is a count to play possibly with
night md3 it's not enough but it is
there
okay check ok so i can take take and
then what not to do why cannot take it
yeah so it's also what's impossible now
it takes d5 now s'okay i will i will
take it
and maybe Luke g1 was a bit too slow
possible wow you can really survive e
six year Wow is six takes root g six
maybe but I have a hard time to believe
that I know it opens up the long
diagonal but but still rook g6 why
should I actually take on b6 first so
that I can swing over with the rook
hmm tough maybe
yeah maybe black can defend that I mean
it looks it looks a tough here with the
rooks double it but if I now take on g6
with the Queen and play there is there
is no made ready Queen g6 look f7 seems
to I don't wait I can take then take
their check hmm if I go rook g6 look f7
our way truck g6 rook f7 rook age six
maybe
look aged six with rook every Queen h7
threatened is this decisive can play is
six
as dangerous as it looks but I'm not
sure it is winning there's e6e m
a threatened queen age seven wow really
time morning we r that is defending them
maybe to be one I would have been better
I'm not threatening to take 95 that's
the problem because of Ruby aid now I
can actually take
now threatening group which is seven and
97 with a winning endgame okay it didn't
materialize the good thing is that I
have a relatively good controller now
here check
check
now to secure the night IAM
so I'm a pawn up which is in itself not
that great but now this is the space
advantage is very nice and these parts
are not that dangerous if she moves away
the rock i can go f6 yeah getting rid of
the doubled pawns threatening group g6
checkmate that is quite quite nice yeah
that's it black cannot defend that if
the check on a fine I have to be
cautious i cannot go to f5 because of
rook f4 which would draw but after the
check where do i go to d3 mp3 is right
and then yeah i can escape on that
square so that's important actually not
not to f5 which is rook a fork King
takes Bishop b3 and it's a it's a draw
black resigns yeah that was final fine a
trickier if I go here it's just
stumbling into a draw Jack I wasn't
seeing that and I cannot keep my pawn
yeah yeah well I'll around here I made I
definitely made mistakes because this is
just winning this position I mean this
is so overwhelming that white should win
but probably rook g1 is the first of a
series of inaccurate moves a computer
wants to do this yeah which is probably
a good prophylactic move if black goes
here I'm doing it like that yeah this is
just a pawn I mean upon with a debt
Bishop here and the big center so unless
I'm blundering material why do in siem
until this is less
less convincing simply yeah this eve
night xt5 here jack which is given as
equal by the engine I find that really
remarkable isn't why just better here I
mean I have an extra king in play but ok
I don't want to look at every line here
so i thought 'i six should be like
winning yeah ok the computer is
basically saying the same book g3 takes
Queen 26 queen g six wins actually I was
thinking maybe I can do yes Queen age
six but i thought 'i six-foot summer who
would i can take on g7 of course yeah i
did i did not see that i can so i didn't
calculate far enough and picking up the
rook okay I saw Queen g6 of course and
but I thought that really this line that
that he can that she can keep it somehow
going with e6 I didn't see this this at
the end okay hmm okay so okay now look
267 here and this move which is really
holding on champ complicated but things
takes ah here's here's a good move that
this is a mistake i guess ii six is
strong interesting other ideas if i take
then my night is is in a deadly pin so I
after you six actually have to retreat
at Black is okay yeah and here step I
started it was it was trouble now with
f5 they have a great coordination
probably on the way to victory yeah now
this is this is winning already
Bishop e7 there is some 98 and here
after this it's a maid I ok I also could
have played this one with the mate
that's even easier ok but I saw I saw
one amazing idea and this is really
enough really cute was that I shouldn't
go here it's good that she took a moment
to give the check so that I could
recognize that not sure if I what I
would have done if she played the check
immediately maybe I would have stumbled
into it yeah this act is drawn ok thanks
for watching